Hi, I'm Aria.
I'm a child wife, content creator.
And today I wanna talk about cosplaying.
I realize I'm probably not changing anyone's mind on this subject,
but I just wanted to touch on it a little bit
because I get the whole cosplaying thing a lot
and I just wanna talk about it.
My main point here,
if you wanna stop now,
is that just because my realistic is not your realistic
doesn't mean that it's fake.
For example, I love skirts and dresses and twirly.
Everything twirly. And bows.
And I'm super feminine and I love that.
And I wear skirts and dresses everyday.
You probably don't.
You might wear jeans everyday,
you might wear a suit everyday.
Okay, that's your real.
That's your life.
This is my life.
That's just me.
I love it. Makes me happy.
If wearing jeans makes you happy
as much as wearing skirts make me happy,
then I am happy for you.
Same with my lifestyle.
The bread winner,
stay at home
mom or wife kind of dynamic of the family is very normal for me.
It's been that way for my mom,
for my grandma,
for my great grandma,
for my great aunts,
my aunts. That's the norm for my family.
But that might not be the norm for your family.
But like I said,
just because my norm is not your norm doesn't mean it's fake.
I love talking about my life and I encourage questions in the comments.
I'd Love to talk to you about this,
but I just want to encourage you to maybe think
before you jump to the conclusion that something is a cosplay.